okay magnus it's uh you're back in
norway is it still does it feel good to
be back after i've been traveling whole
june
yes
i was expecting it to be a little bit
nicer here though
um
i went with some of my friends
for
yeah
just for a barbecue uh
on the beach yesterday
and we were wondering why there was no
one there uh-huh
it started raining so we kind of
figured out why
and uh it was nice despite of bad
weather so that was your feelings uh
after the stavanger tournament and
before and when you went to dubai you
had been playing a
tough tournament and then you had
five days so
really heavy tough program ahead of you
did you
feel prepared for that when you went
yeah um
i have to say my confidence level wasn't
at the very highest
after the norwegians tournament
since things hadn't been going so
smoothly there
and
then
on the first day there
i decided for some reason to uh to watch
all the football games which uh finished
uh seven in the morning on that
particular day that's the first day uh
no not the first turn that was actually
the day i arrived so there will be
another rest day but that kind of
screwed up my sleeping rhythm a little
bit so
really
although the the game started at
three the other days that was just
just enough time to get
eight nine hours and then
and then then get up
i i felt like this rapid didn't start so
well uh
in the [ __ ] first few games i
i
my play was a little bit tentative kind
of the way it had been in norway chess
the second day started
okay with uh with a pretty interesting
draw against karjakin and then against
fascinate first i played
a
bad opening for some reason
and
then um i was a little bit worse perhaps
but
he played too passively and i took over
and that at some point i
i just needed to protect
the pawn and i was going to
to protect it with a bishop
but
that i was trying to decide what to do
next and suddenly i picked up the brook
instead of the bishop and i just froze
completely and i didn't
have the presence of mine to put the
to put the rook on the one square where
it actually could
um
where it actually protected my key pawn
um did you have time trouble at that
moment no not at all he had like one
minute left i had seven eight minutes
so
it was just a terrible lapse of
concentration and then after i lost that
pawns pawn my position was basically in
ruins but
thanks to some too passive
play for him maybe he had too much
respect for me
although he doesn't always give that
impression
i managed to save the game
so then i was at um
well less than stellar score of five
from seven
but um
i felt that this was the time to
to actually start playing dc chess so
then the last three games of the day i
played well and finished with the lead
eight out of ten was a that's really
good start after
after two days and you had the last day
left
five five rounds to go oh uh you you
were in the lead but just by half a
point yeah about half a point over
aronian who
had had a really good day too
and uh
searched into second place with seven
and a half in my game with him i was
under serious pressure i managed to find
first a lot of good moves
to stay afloat
he also found all the right moves to put
pressure on me
um
and then i started to drift
um
a bit
i was trying to somehow simplify the
game but
he kept on finding some resources
um
to
to keep me from doing that
at some point um my king was in serious
danger
but at the same time several his of his
pieces were hanging so the computer
showed that he had a win there
um
but the way he played the most natural
way
i could just
about escape into
a defensible position so that was a
narrow escape um
that was the first round yeah that was
the first round of the third day so i
kept my
half a point lead i was curious if you
had any chance did you feel that you had
any chances when you got the two rooks
against the queen no i felt that my king
was just too exposed
and i feel like in rapid chess it's very
often
easier to
to play with um
with the queen than the two rooks i mean
besides my my bishop was a little bit
out of play at the first time
at first and
actually right
right about the final position is the
best position i've had for a long time
with two rooks and a pawn against queen
and pawn but
i didn't see any realistic opportunities
to win
um
it seemed like that by playing on i
would be the one who is risking more so
i decided to be
pragmatic there for
for a change that was a okay start of
the third day that you were
definitely but i was i was absolutely
drained by that game
yeah and then for my next game with anan
i i
did something very wrong in the opening
so he immediately gained a small
advantage
then i managed to turn it around
he played a combination um
netting him
a rook for a knight in a bishop and
a
distant past pawn which he thought might
give him an advantage but it became
pretty clear
that uh he was the one who had to play
for a draw
and yeah then i just
blundered a piece in one move
that's very untypical yeah
i mean the
the very simple um
skewer that you had of my
rookie bishop just no i mean my nighting
just
escaped me completely did you feel it
when it took tonight no not at all i
didn't see that i didn't i didn't miss
it
no uh i was
obsessed with that he would play rook v3
instead i thought that was his idea so i
spent all my time calculating even
usually when you do these things when
you put the piece down then you
then you just
okay then you just immediately realize
that you brother
nothing of the sort happened to me i
i just put the piece down and i didn't
realize anything before he
he moved the rook all the way back
so
that was a huge flow
and
you had to
it was not like that you just could
resign immediately you had to try to
defend yeah i had to try i had to try
and defend i mean the position was
was uh
was lost but it was not kind of those
one of those completely lost positions
he did the job very very nicely and
however long i searched
there was there were just no how was the
situation in the tournament after that
game
were still in the uh no i i was half a
point behind anand and karana who were
playing each other yeah in in the next
round and uh
if you were trained after the game first
game against aronian how did you feel
after the game against hanon no just
awful
but uh what did you do to pull yourself
together to be ready for the third game
that day well nothing in in particular
i was slightly encouraged that by my
next opponent uh would be the chinese yu
yang yi instead of one of the real
um
real top guns since i clearly needed to
win that game with black and
even though he had done very well it
seemed to be an easier task to do to do
it against him
than
one of the others
then i
the opening went very well
he sacrificed a pawn but he hadn't seen
far enough so i could consolidate
and um
emerge upon up for
very little compensation
i certainly didn't convert it in in the
best way but there are there there
wasn't a clear draw for him i think at
any point and eventually i managed to
yeah to uh to squeeze out again and that
was a relief i guess and that got you in
yeah
that got me in back in shared first
place since karana and anand made the
draw yeah and carvanha had a completely
dominating position in that game but he
allowed a
a tactic that
um
that anand used to uh to to liquidate uh
to to a drawn end game yeah
when you played great ship again yeah
then i played greg um
recalled some feelings from uh yeah from
uh from astana 2012 when you also were
in a i believe before the last day but
you lost to
um okay and came in second yes i
actually
very very i barely saved second place in
that tournament that could even have
been 30 if i lost
in the last round so
um
i was gonna say he he outplayed me from
from the outset
i i missed
several things in the opening
and he exploited my mistakes very
energetically at some point i felt that
i
i regret regain the threat that i'd lost
um in the opening but
at that point when was that no just um
in the
from moves 15 to 20 or something like
that i felt like i i did
everything i needed to do um to
to have a more or less acceptable
position then he temporarily sacrificed
the form which i
i'd expected what i hadn't expected was
how bad my position turned out to be
afterwards because
it seemed that i would not only
lose the pawn but
i would lose
uh at least one more pawn and my
king king's position would be
would be ruined
uh so i just thought for a really long
time uh that was amazing how long uh
still i had no time left so in despair i
did
what i thought was
was the best chance um
to just at least hang on a little bit
um
then
he could have won
more quickly but it wasn't that easy to
see
when i got my knight f2 uh i felt that
there were some
some chances to
to escape uh at least didn't feel like i
would be mated anytime soon and even if
he wins the pawn
on c5 which he certainly will
there will be some
some chances to escape
either in the middle game or maybe even
in the end game
well from that on
things
when
well
beyond my wildest expectations uh
he started to get low on time
as well
and
he gave me an opportunity to win back
the pawn which looked
a little bit
dangerous but i
more or less calculated i that i could
afford it and that the attack he had on
the king side turned out to be
less dangerous than expected so
after that we had night i had quite
queen and night and three points against
queen bishop and
and three pawns but i had a past pawn so
i
thought with and and
with
little time the knight is often
um an effective piece more effective
than the bishop so i thought how do you
give perhaps that momentum yeah i had
the momentum and managed to
to
coordinate my pieces quite well protect
my king
retain that vital kingside pawn that i
needed
enable
in order to have any winning chances
whatsoever um
and um
yeah you won and
and i won
how did you feel after that no
huge huge
relief it was um
it was sort of a candidate's moment for
for me like after the game with
a job off where
everything
seemed to be lost but then
in some crucial minutes it all turned
around and then
as it was you had the best tie breaks
well pete ryan and i sat down
just to to look
at the tie breaks the the main
the main factor there was the average
rating of my opponent of my opponents
and it seemed that no matter what
happened i would have the best scorer
there
actually the only one who had the better
um
tie break among the best was carvana but
he could only catch me if i
if i lost yeah and you you made it raw
in the last yeah
saved ron
as aronia didn't manage to win a winning
position against anandam yeah you can
clear first and that was
of course huge because
you had prior to tournament you had
said that the other goal
oh yeah definitely um
so
i thought before the tournament um
my goal was to
to gain four out of five on every day
um so i scored four out of five on the
first two days but then only three
from five on the last day but it
nevertheless turned out to be
to be enough so you have
achieved your goal to win the rapid
championship and
that was a good feeling i guess
oh definitely
it was a very tough
tournament
with with so many good players
it's very hard to to end up ahead uh no
matter how big a favorite you are
before
tournament there were many
difficult moments but
in the
end
the little bit of luck was wasn't my
size